Hi, everyone.
I am excited to be here and really, really
excited we get to start the day off and the
conference talking about peer-to-peer protocols
because it is something I think is super fascinating
and I have interesting stuff to show off later
in my talk.
This talk is called reclaiming the web with
peer-to-peer protocols but before I dive in
and tell you what in the world that is all
about, I want to introduce myself.
I am Tara Vancil and I am a web developer.
I'm also really, really into anything to do
with nails and nail art and I love music,
especially if it is from Beyonce.
If you like nails or Beyonce or both we should
definitely talk later on.
I am a web developer but I have spent the
last year and a half in a strange role.
Instead of working on a team where my job
is to build websites, I have been building
a browser with these two guys.
Pfrazza and mafintosh.
We have experiments we want to run and figure
the browser is the best place to do that.
The browser is called Beaker and it is experimental
way meaning we are doing experiments in the
science way not that it is buggy.
It actually works.
You can download it.
The cool experience we are running in Beaker
is what happens when you put a peer-to-peer
protocol in the browser.
Pretty interesting things happen like being
able to publish a website from the browser
and being able to offer experimental peer-to-peer
APIs to developers.
I will tell you a lot more about Beaker and
show you Beaker later.
Before I do that, I want to spend some time
to reflect on what even is the web because
I think it is relevant to your conversation.
-- our.
So, I am asking this to reclaim the web and
we should probably talk about who took it
in the first place and what have they done
with it.
We are all here in this room at a conference
dedicated to the web so surely the web can't
be in too much trouble; right?
I have to agree.
I am extremely optimistic about the future
of the web.
I am really pleased with where the web is
at right now.
I am really happy to see so many new people
still coming to the web every day to learn
how to build things with HTML, and JavaScript,
and CSS.
I am pleased to see that the tools we depend
on like NPM and WebPack and Babel are improving
to make workflows seamless.
And I am thrilled browsers are working hard
to improve the web and compatibility across
browsers.
If you are not optimistic about the web, I
might highlight the Chrome Developer summit
happened this weekend.
This is an opportunity for Chrome developers
to share ideas and prototypes about how the
web is going to move forward.
They announced cool proposals like virtual
scrolling which should help you improve loading
as you scroll down a page and other neat stuff
was demoed like Houdini which is an improvement
on how CSS works.
Seeing the neat announcements earlier this
week gave me time to reflect on the wins of
the web like CSS grid which if I dare say
makes com posing layouts kind of fun or the
fact that Boku has been working hard with
the W3C and other browser vendors to build
a huge test sweep for compatibility across
the web.
The web is making progress and I think it
is important to recognize that and the people
that make it happen because their jobs are
not easy.
Also because the web is a miracle of human
cooperation if you think about it.
When you take a second to think about what
the web is it is a miracle it exists and let
alone that it is improving.
The web is this strange thing where 7 billion
people on earth have come together and decided
on a language for how we build digital stuff
and get it from one computer to another.
Like, that is absolutely miraculous we pulled
that off.
You have a web page and no matter what context
you are browsing in, you have a reasonable
expectation it will work consistently.
If you will allow me a moment to be sentimental
I just want to say I think that is bad ass.
This is a talk about reclaiming the web, though.
Even though I am really optimistic about the
web, I am a little bit worried too.
I am worried about the web isn't perfect and
honestly that is OK especially when you think
about how this web is a weird amorphous set
of technologies that we have all agreed to
use and that is pretty much the only thing
binding it together; our shared agreedness
to use it.
The web is only 28 years old.
The first was built in 1990 by Tim Burners-Lee.
It was only 25 years ago the first mainstream
browser was released.
We are operating on a small time scale here.
The web is a baby so you would expect it to
have some problems.
The web isn't perfect.
We can accept that but I think the next step
is to ask ourselves how are we going to shape
the next 30 years and I mean, we, the people
in the room who are web developers and people
who influence standards, we do have say over
how the web works.
We know that the web is going to change because
there are standards of bodies and browser
vendors and other interested parties who want
to shake the web but the question is what
values are why going to choose to uphold in
the next 30 years?
What new features are we going to enable?
How do we decide those things?
Oftentimes, I think they are decided by personal
experience.
Some of you probably work with e-commerce
and you might be paying more attention to
the web payments API.
Or maybe some of you in this room have been
the target of a focused-harassment campaign
on social media and you might have an interest
in seeing how the web learns from what we
have seen about how humans engage online in
the last 28 years.
The web is very, very new and we are still
learning so much about how communities work
online and how humans behave.
When I think about what I want to web to look
like in 30 years, honestly the community bit
of it is what interests me the most.
Yeah, the graphics and all the cool technical
stuff about the web is amazing and it is what
makes the web the web but we come to the web
because we want to talk to me.
We want to share interests, make friendships
and form communities.
I am extremely interested to ask how can the
web platform itself change, however subtly,
the ways we interact with each or online.
Whether you like it or not, this guy right
now has a lot of say over how online communities
work.
And I am not sure he knew what he was getting
into when he started Facebook but the point
is Facebook is a massive, global online community
and we have learned some kind of terrifying
things about humans interacting with each
other online.
We are mean, we are nasty, we are reactive,
we are just not very good at talking to each
other, are we?
This guy and other folks are in charge of
helping us move forward.
I frankly don't think they have stepped up
to that responsibility very well.
I want us, as web developers and a web community,
to think about what can we do to adjust how
people talk to each other online?
Are there some nobs we can turn in terms of
the technical architecture of the web that
can improve the situation?
I don't know but this question motivated me
to work on Beaker and it has been the guiding
star in my exploration and the experiments
we have been running at Beaker.
So to go back to the question I mentioned
earlier, what happens when you put a peer-to-peer
protocol in the browser?
Would that be the right knob to turn to maybe
make it a little nicer to communicate with
people online?
I don't know.
I can show you some of the experiments we
have done and share some of the things we
have learned in the process.
Before where do that, let's just take a look
at HTTP because this is the knob we turn in
Beaker.
The protocol knob.
This is the distillation of how HTTP works.
It is a client server model where one person
can upload data to let's say Facebook, Twitter,
WhatsApp.
A person gets the data from the service and
there is nothing wrong with that architecture,
but I would like to propose HTP and this client
server architecture is a big part of why we
have gotten the way -- a big part of why online
communities, massive online communities, have
turned out to be so problematic.
In contrast, this is what a web base on a
peer-to-peer protocol looks like.
This is a contrived example but it is a network
wherein one individual can connect directly
to another individual.
In this case, we are looking at someone sending
a message but we can also think of websites
being transmitted from computer-to-computer
and cutting out servers.
Why don't I just show you Beaker because I
think it is a lot more exciting to see this
stuff in action.
This is Beaker.
It is a browser.
It is not terribly exciting to look at when
you are just looking at the start page but
it works like you would expect a browser to
work.
You can browse HTTP websites.
This is the Beaker website and nothing remarkable
here.
But if you can see in the top corner there
is a tab that says P2P version.
When I like that it will take me to the peer-to-peer
version of this website.
There is.
You probably didn't even see that.
The only thing that's different is the protocol.
It says dat and that is the protocol we use
in Beaker.
This website doesn't look like anything special.
It is just a bunch of files, CSS, HTML images,
links, everything.
It works just the way you would expect a browser
to work.
I mentioned that by putting a P2P protocol
in the browser we enabled things like publishing
a website from the browser.
I am show that off.
I will go to the top-right menu and click
create view and I will create a website using
a pasted template Beaker provides.
Beaker will literally create a new URL for
me and populate the website with basic template
files.
I will click it and it will happen fast.
Boom.
We are looking at Beaker's view source tool
here.
I will show you more but let me set the title
of the website for now.
Then I will open it up.
Here it is.
It is just a website.
It doesn't do anything except let you change
the background color.
What is interesting about this is this is
a website and I can share the URL with any
of you and you can download the website and
files directly from me.
I didn't publish the files on a server anywhere.
I did it all inside the browser.
How do you edit websites?
If we jump back to the view source tool we
can look at all the files that compose a website.
Why don't we open index.html and actually
edit it.
I will change this to say hello, Seattle.
Hit the save button.
When I refresh I will see the change.
Cool.
I want to show off this neat feature we have
which is live view loading.
We put that right into the browser because
it is so convenient.
Like a lot of us in this room who are developers,
we probably have a preference about writing
code like Sublime or VS code.
This syncs the files to a directory on my
computer.
OK.
I am going to open this up in Sublime and
open the index.html in Sublime and go back
to this website.
We have live view loading on and I will edit
the H1 tag to say hello from Sublime and when
I hit save you will see the updates.
Boom.
There we go.
This is neat but I mentioned earlier that
Beaker also has peer-to-peer APIs.
This is really where it gets exciting because
static websites are cool and make up a lot
of the web.
They are not every part of the web.
We still need applications where people can
have profiles and data linked to their profiles.
Beaker's APIs are the key to making that possible.
I am going to open the dev tools and show
you a little bit of how this works.
To start off, we need to get access to the
files that compose this website.
I am going to do that using Beaker's datarchive
constructor which basically gives you
access to the functions that help you connect
to the peer-to-peer network.
We have a variable that we will be able to
work with here.
Let's start off with just listing all the
files in this website.
You might notice this looks a lot like the
Node files API and that was on purpose.
Let's do files.readdir and we will read the
top level directory.
Then we will console.log the output.
We are seeing a listing of all files that
compose this website.
There is only 65 of them right now.
Let's see if we can read an individual file,
the content file.
So files.readFile and let's do index.html
file.
We are looking at the actual content of this
page now.
We can do all sorts of things like readfiles,
readfile listing, and we can write two files
also.
This gets interesting when you think about
storing data in websites.
I am actually going to overwrite the HTML
file for this website.
Files.writeFile and I am going to replace
it with a new h1 tag.
OK.
Now when I refresh I get a totally new index
with HTML.
Again, this is sort of a contrived example
but I want to take it back to a real world
example.
I said I am interested in thinking about how
online communities can be shaped by the intelligent
that underpins them.
I want to show you an application that we
built called Fritter.
This is Fritter.
As you can probably guess by the name and
appearance, it is inspired by Twitter.
That was on purpose.
I really like Twitter.
I like a lot of things about Twitter.
I dislike some things about Twitter but I
like that it gives me a nice feed, I can follow
my friends on, and I like that the content
is short, sweet, and enjoyable most of the
time.
So, we said how far can we get with building
something like Twitter using peer-to-peer
protocols and we got pretty far actually.
It is pretty cool.
This doesn't look like much but I will break
down the architecture.
Fritter works in two pieces.
There is the application itself which is what
we are looking at.
It is a JavaScript application that uses Beaker's
APIs to consume a profile and fetch data from
the peer-to-peer network and render it into
a nice feed.
When I write a post, Beaker uses the writefile
API to write a post to my profile.
Works like you would expect.
But what does a profile actually look like?
What is a profile?
Well, it is not a row and database that lives
up in a server somewhere.
It is just a website.
This is it.
It has some metadata.
My name, my bio, well this is a fake profile,
it has information about the people I follow,
and it contains my posts in JSON.
This is interesting because we separated the
data from the application which is not news.
We are used to doing that as developers but
what is different is your profile on Fritter
is just a website.
It is not tied to Fritter.
If you wanted to customize your own version
of Fritter you could do that and you wouldn't
need to give up your circle of friends or
content.
You could carry on like normal.
I think this demonstrates a lot of potential
for building meaningful applications with
peer-to-peer protocols.
This is my demo profile.
There are posts from my friends, like two
friends.
And people talk to each other.
I am not going to say this is the ideal architecture
for moving forward on the peer-to-peer web
or it won't have its own kind of problems.
But it is a kind of community controlled social
media and that's really, really exciting to
me because if there is anything I have learned
about being a woman online in the last year
and a half is that sometimes you really do
want to take control over who you do and don't
talk to because otherwise it gets a little
bit noisy.
So that is a quick and dirty tour of Beaker.
We are experimenting.
We are doing a lot of things that are strange
and most certainly don't adhere to what is
standard but we think it is worthwhile to
be a little messy and see what happens.
We don't have the kind of reputation like
Apple or Mozilla or Google does to influence
standards bodies.
We are just random people who had an idea
and we built it.
We hope you will find it interesting.
If you want to try out Beaker and see what
other people have built I recommend checking
out my website.
I have the P2P subdomain on my website.
I have a huge selection of apps, games, and
other things people have built on the peer-to-peer
web.
Thank you for coming to learn about Beaker
and the peer-to-peer web.
Come talk to me later and you can check out
the slides on my website.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]